Stranger Things 3 is without a doubt the big
release for July, but there's plenty more
to look forward to.
Here's a look at everything good coming to
Netflix in July 2019, starting with the Netflix
originals.
History buffs aren't the only audience for
Netflix's upcoming The Last Czars.
The series will combine documentary-style
information plugs with dramatic reenactments
to trace the history of Czar Nicholas II,
Russia's last emperor.
Let's put it this way: If your only knowledge
of the Romanovs, the February Revolution,
and Rasputin comes from watching Anastasia
as a kid, get ready for a whole new world
of insight into the revolution that brought
the Romanov dynasty to its knees.
Tune in for the entire series when it arrives
on July 3rd.
There probably isn't a single person watching
this who needs a recap of Stranger Things.
Netflix's throwback horror/fantasy series
took the streaming world by storm in 2016,
then upped the insanity with Season 2 in 2017.
It's hard to believe that nearly two years
have passed since we last saw Eleven and her
friends battle the forces of the Upside Down,
but it looks like the wait was more than worth
it.
Stranger Things 3 sees the kids a little older,
and hopefully a little wiser, as their hometown
of Hawkins, Indiana, is once again threatened
by otherworldly beasts.
Take a look when Stranger Things 3 arrives
on July 4th.
Don't let the subtitles turn you off to Cities
of Last Things.
If you're a fan of gritty psychological thrillers
like Memento or Jacob's Ladder, you'll have
a good time watching this dystopian Taiwanese
film.
Told in reverse chronological order, the story
follows a depressed ex-cop whose life is on
a downward spiral.
Beginning with one shocking act, Cities of
Last Things then backtracks over the three
days leading up to his fateful decision.
Look for it to hit Netflix on July 11th.
Anthony Mackie takes the lead in Point Blank
as a nurse on the hunt for the criminals who
kidnapped his pregnant wife.
To bring the thugs to justice, he'll have
to team up with the suspect of a murder investigation,
played by Frank Grillo, and descend into the
criminal underworld.
"Where are you going?
I'm gonna kill them.
All of them."
Point Blank is a remake of the 2011 French
thriller of the same name, and Netflix couldn't
have picked a better source for their film.
The original garnered a 91 percent approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes, with critics praising
the sharp action and furious pace.
Look for Point Blank to land on Netflix on
July 12th.
How do you give audiences a fresh take on
the age-old Frankenstein story?
Easy: You do whatever the hell Netflix is
doing with Frankenstein's Monster's Monster,
Frankenstein.
Not only is that a tongue twister of a title,
it also looks like a brain twister of a story.
Stranger Things' David Harbour stars in this
short mockumentary as a man who's digging
into his father's past to uncover secrets
about an old Frankenstein-themed play.
What does it all mean?
We'll have to wait until July 16th to find
out, when Frankenstein's Monster's Monster,
Frankenstein shows up on Netflix.
Secret Obsession centers on a woman named
Jennifer, played by The Social Network's Brenda
Song, who wakes up to a headful of amnesia
and a husband who may be keeping dangerous
secrets from her.
Mike Vogel co-stars as Jennifer's husband
Russel.
Netflix has so far only teased the upcoming
film, but all signs point to a tense, edge-of-your-seat
thriller.
Take a look on July 18th.
If you're one of the avid watchers of La Casa
de Papel, or Money Heist, you're no doubt
pumped about the series' return.
According to Deadline, it's the streaming
service's most popular non-English language
series, and if you've ever given it a chance
you know that it's worth the hype.
Even if you haven't tried it, you might still
recognize it as the one with all the people
in masks and red jumpsuits.
Without giving too much away, the show basically
involves an elaborate heist on the Spanish
Royal Mint.
Originally slated as a limited series in Spain,
Netflix commissioned a third part in early
2018, most likely due to the overwhelming
popularity of the series.
If this is your first run-in with Money Heist,
you still have plenty of time to catch up
before Part 3 arrives on July 19th.
We're not entirely sure what to expect with
this upcoming sci-fi series, but hopefully
Another Life turns out just as good as it
looks.
Katee Sackhoff stars as an astronaut who's
leading a crew into space to check out a mysterious
alien artifact.
Another Life comes from creator Aaron Martin,
who also created Netflix's horror series Slasher
- another show worth checking out for horror
fans.
Take a look at Another Life when the first
season arrives on July 25th.
Fans who have followed Orange is the New Black
for six seasons are surely getting excited
about the upcoming series finale.
Season 7 sees Piper out of prison and trying
to cope with her life in the outside world,
but finding it tougher than she expected.
Much of the cast has come forward to shed
a light on their feelings about the series'
end, with most conceding that it's a bittersweet
finale.
Tune in for the final season of Orange is
the New Black when it premieres on July 26th.
Netflix is closing out the month with The
Red Sea Diving Resort, a political action
thriller starring Chris Evans as the leader
of a team working to get Ethiopian refugees
to safety.
According to BBC, the premise is based on
a real life resort in Sudan that was set up
by Mossad agents in the '80s.
It's an intriguing story, and we can't wait
to see what Chris Evans does with the role.
Look for it on July 31st.
That covers all the best new Netflix originals
for July; let's pivot now to check out the
rest of the films heading our way.
Netflix is clearly focusing the month on its
original films and series, and while there's
plenty to look forward to there, there aren't
a lot of licensed genre films to look forward
to.
Action is taking a real hit, with only four
additions in July, all of which arrive on
the 1st.
Fortunately, they're all worth a watch - even
if it's a rewatch.
1989's Road House is showing up, right beside
2001's Swordfish, 2010's The Book of Eli,
and 2005's offbeat fantasy adventure comedy
The Brothers Grimm.
Similarly, there are only three new thriller
additions in the thriller genre.
Look for 2006's Mean Dreams, which marks Bill
Paxton's final film role.
Mean Dreams is a dramatic thriller about a
boy named Jonas who sees his father, a corrupt
police officer, steal a satchel of drug money.
Jonas takes the money and leaves with his
girlfriend, looking for a better life, but
it isn't long before his own father begins
hunting him down.
You can catch Mean Dreams on July 1, along
with everyone's favorite shaky monster movie,
Cloverfield, and Scream 3.
"It's your turn to scream, a------."
On the drama front, Netflix is adding some
of the more obscure, earlier Martin Scorcese
films, including 1973's Mean Streets, 1974's
Alice Doesn't Live Here Anymore, and 1967's
Who's That Knocking at My Door?
All of those arrive on July 1st.
Other additions on the first of the month
include Oscar winners Rain Man and Philadelphia,
with 2011's The Iron Lady coming on the 6th.
Finally, close out the month with Quentin
Tarantino's World War II opus Inglourious
Basterds on the 22nd.
Notable comedy additions include both Caddyshack
films, The Hangover, and the two Pink Panther
reboot films, if you're into that kind of
thing.
Those all show up on the first.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Netflix shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.